ah
[Música]
hola qué tal mucho gusto yo soy jerry
hernández lara estoy muy feliz de estar
aquí para empezar es mi primer
conferencia plática yo también soy un
alumno este estoy en la ibero la verdad
estoy viviendo un sueño de estar
corriendo carreras más concretamente el
rally yo alavés de ser piloto funde un
equipo de carreras que va a estar en el
dock 13 en marzo en la siguiente semana
con nuestro piloto ricardo cordero y la
verdad estoy muy feliz de vivir un sueño
de estar haciendo ahora pláticas cosas
que yo no pensaba que podía pasar no sé
si se cumplen y yo quiero hablar de un
tema que la verdad
y al estar poniendo toda mi vida y la de
mi copiloto en estar corriendo
en él a toda velocidad la verdad es que
yo estoy a expensas de de que consiste
bien de toda mi inteligencia de estar
activa lo que tiene que pasar si no
algún accidente y yo puedo pues perder y
va a salir salir muy lastimado entonces
a quien lo que yo quiero platicar es
cuando me regreso es que llueve pero
lynn diaria pueden afectar mucho a la
población y a la gente porque no lo
hacemos en un espacio controlado de
carreras
pues para empezar si quiera que el caso
número 18 que es en méxico es por
accidentes de alcance porque más
distraído en el teléfono porque vas
platicando porque conteste una llamada
que sean que ella es que fue rápido yo
creo que de entradas algo que ustedes ya
saben que no se debe hacer pero ya no es
un tema ni siquiera de información ya es
un tema de inteligencia porque se le
preguntó
eres inteligente vas a decir que sí
misma que mi alma no soy inteligente
entonces si eres inteligente y ya sabes
que eso es algo que no se debe hacer
porque no está tomando decisiones
inteligentes detrás del volante entonces
aquí lo más importante es que tú estés
cuidando a los terceros que puede ser
este caso del papá / estudio el papá de
personas que no conoces pero que también
quiere llegar a su casa que por
pertenece una rápida está distrayendo
estas ocasiones un accidente por eso yo
estoy totalmente convencido que son
acciones que si empezamos a considerar
vamos a empezar a cuidarnos entre
nosotros el tema del alcohol también así
yo les preguntara que cuánta gente
conocen que ha tenido una desgracias por
qué vive el crimen organizado
narcotráfico etcétera
en realidad es pensar que son pocas
donde los que estamos aquí pero si nos
dijera cuántos conocen que han tenido un
accidente por qué porque estaban tomando
un conocido que le pasó a él la verdad
es que son más las personas que están
expuestas a todo esto y están pagando
los platos rotos gente que ni debería y
es doloroso que tengamos que parar bien
que que me la debe no la teme
este tener consecuencias cuando ni
siquiera me está pasando esto hay un
ejemplo claro entre el pésimo pero que
dicen este que vas manejando y te tapan
los ojos
entonces vendrá ese cuerpo técnico
porque no estás viendo lo que pasa y si
estás consciente de que será distinto a
9 real camino estás dejando de poner
atención tampoco irá a regañarlos pero
son son acciones que al final tienen una
consecuencia y la cosa es que hay que
cuidarnos este por ejemplo si también
ya sabemos que la fiesta que vas a tomar
aquí se va a relajar a bien que sabemos
para pagar un taxi porque un amigo te
llevo dos papas o quince a pagar la
cárcel del que pagar las horas que todo
lo que conlleva la verdad
no es algo que la gente quisiera
experimentar más cuando nos ayuda en
caso concreto los papás de dos amigos
han perdido la vida por cosas de este
tipo otros primos han tenido accidentes
severos conocidas que han tenido cosas
si te pone a pensar en el día también se
usa mucho está estudiando que aunque sea
que ellos tengan ambiente sea campeón de
mi categoría y estamos haciendo las
cosas bien la verdad es que para mí ni
siquiera es de nuestros los
fundamentales empecé a contagiar a la
gente con quien dice no haber se cuenta
que con que alguien si se empape de esto
que lo hagas un poquito más con 77
origen manda el mensaje no pasa nada que
ponga su intermitente este padre soleado
fuentes es el mensaje que las llama me
cables por teléfono porque te esperes el
auto tan siquiera posee entonces tan mis
curvas pero que a la vez tiene un
impacto tan grande que en breve se a
nadie nos gustaría perder un segundo y
nada más nuestra vida como que vamos a
proyectar en el que vale la pena tener
un un tiempo de espera el llegar de
minutos tarde cinco minutos el que estar
pagando los plátanos con este tipo
otro tema muy importante el que dos casi
todos los hombres que traen un coche o
que de repente sean los que es lo que
quieren si sienten acá que van con un
hacha de lo que sea creen que son
pilotos creen que están en la pista en
el al cuadro armando rodríguez que
pueden ir haciendo atrás
sus bajas acrobacias y derrapando
pisándole además la grada es que hay
lugares para hacerlo que por eso alguien
más también fue un chavo más rápidamente
que a veces llegué a hacer estas cosas
tenía conocidos que le hacían
experimentar los males de sus emociones
te das cuenta que puede subsistir pero
siguieron equipos a nuestros
profesionales también conocemos más
gente en el medio la verdad no va a ser
en tu vida
al final un coche la velocidad para
pisarle hasta mi abuelita si le pongo el
coche de rally
y mi hábitat está viviendo la
universidad que yo llevo pero aquí no se
trata de una piedra del acelerador y vas
a llegar igual o se ha perdido la
ilusión cualquiera de la garra más bien
son cosas hábitos que hay que hacer
nosotros o sea la concha que tenemos en
un coche las cuatro llantas es lo único
que te pega al hueso
acá se revisa estudiantes o sea leche
cyrus en bolsa de vez en cuando éste te
pones a revisar sólo el mantenimiento de
su coche igual como sociedad para
escucharlos no todos están en el mismo
canal excelencia hace fácil que pone una
cosita pues después para platos rotos
cuando pues no vale la pena
las carreras que digamos poquito más
conciencia que si un doctor por ejemplo
el caso no es exactamente el mismo de
acuerdo yo me dediqué a esto yo me
dedico a exponer mi vida a correr que es
al final el día de mañana yo no sé si
puedo pasar al siguiente pero nosotros
hacemos en el entorno cuidando las tres
medidas de seguridad
2 imagínate si a los pilotos que tenemos
pasa todo eso están listos y espasa
nosotros quedamos que ganamos dinero que
eso nos gritamos imagínate alguien más
normal como todos estamos súper
expuestos en realidad hay una
estadística que es el 60 por ciento de
probabilidad que por antelación por
distraer te vas a tener algún choque
entonces
me gusta más conciencia
[Música]
seamos más pues
conscientes por lo que puede pasar
[Música]
seamos la verdad gente que hagamos el
cambio no quedamos sobre el que no les
pasen las palabras y yo sé que es un
tema súper aburrido que todos dicen que
desde stamp años de tránsito que le
hacen otros lados que dice que evita mis
imágenes tomadas y ya sé ya sé pero que
te lo dicen por nada es porque en
realidad tiene sentido tiene tienen
fundamento
entonces sí sí hay que prestar atención
sí hay que estar súper tanto por ejemplo
vienen real la gente que tenga el color
que quiera basura hay muchísima gente
que está en el tiempo real y si sale de
nuestra música en piloto lo que fuiste
al cine a ver rápidos y furiosos y crees
que tú serás torre tomé a salir igual de
la palma va para un poco por ese pero
sólo hay que también de saber cómo el
coche te tienes que sentar como tienes
que ver la vista los ojos este coche no
te pegue en la cabeza son muy bonitos
técnicos pero que valen muchísimo la
pena
dejemos al salón será que no importa ya
y entonces pues yo estoy contento por
primera una plática de que estarían en
el tiempo de que estamos aquí está
compartiendo un rato pero puedes
aprovecharlo aunque sea para quedaremos
con algo que yo bienvenida aquí
completamente feliz con que sólo por una
persona de aquí aunque si nadie me hizo
caso si lo que está bien conducida por
una persona tome conciencia y salve una
vida si evita la primera menos que se
puede perder un accidente menos y yo con
eso estoy feliz no me importa si los
otros 200 personas con que era una
persona se quede comenzó vamos a irnos a
casa felices vamos a seguir jugando
nosotros vamos a seguir conviviendo
súper bien y entonces
[Música]
por su tiempo
yo estoy totalmente convencido que si lo
podemos poner en práctica podemos
comenzar a mejorar nuestra sociedad y
pues no les agradezco mucho por estar
aquí
y gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]